notre métier n'est pas de gérer des
stades
c'est pas notre métier de base notre
métier c'est de d'organiser la pratique
du rugby en France pour autant vous me
direz il y a des fédérations qui sont
propriétaires de leur stade c'est le cas
de la Fédération anglaise
qui avait tout un homme
qui a quand même eu du mal à passer le
covid enfin je pense qu'on devait le
savoir
puisque un PSE a été mis en place par
cette fédération et on a toutes les
raisons de penser que les charges liées
à l'exploitation du stade de trucs un
homme a été quelque part à l'origine
enfin une des origines de CPS
ce s'étendait me poser la question si on
sait que certains avec le président
Diallo sur ce sujet là on doit se
rencontrer prochainement on évoque à ce
sujet on l'a pas fait
on doit se rencontrer au cours du mois
d'avril donc c'est très proche on l'a
pas fait
notre posture aujourd'hui est une
posture plutôt d'attente et de
neutralité pourquoi parce que vous
l'avez ça a été évoqué tout à l'heure
dans le les appels d'offres ont été
signifié que les matchs des fédérations
françaises de foot et des fédérations
françaises de rugby match internationaux
devrait se tenir au Stade de France
c'est que quelque part nous avons une
garantie par rapport au futur
lauréat de
l'appel d'offre dans deux appels
d'offres quand au fait que le Stade de
France sera toujours à disposition de
nos équipes pour effectivement que les
matchs correspondants se déroulent